if this is the very last game for magnus
in the 2021 yeah and uh wow
this is uh stubborn he says hey i'm
gonna do that line again it didn't work
out last time it wasn't the fault of the
opening necessarily but look at this 1v3
when in doubt copycat just mirror that
opening and black has played one b6
and white has a push forward with the
kingsporn taking a stake in the center
okay and black's bishop coming out this
is the point after all of making those
pawn pushers at the side of the board to
develop your bishop to their long
diagonals and now magnus carson has
brought his knight out to defend that
central pawn and do the same here as
black feels like time to push a pawn
okay he just pushes one square forward
releasing the black dark squared bishop
now magnus will he bring his own dark
square bishop out there we go it's on
its dream diagonal it's blocked by its
own knight right now but if the white
knight ever moves then this bishop will
be a key piece and uh okay the knight
attacks the pawn in the center i was
just gonna say if wesley picks up his uh
c7 pawn and pushes it two squares the
line would actually transpose two lines
that we see against the sicilian to move
for a second
turn early in the game and yep so far so
good all in my database
and okay the black knight does jump to
this square i saw also recently there
were games of the black knight jumping
to a different square meanwhile after
this trade we see the white queen coming
out so magnus carlsen has not hidden his
intentions to win this game he's going
on the attack early and that white queen
pinning down some of the black pieces
she's getting ready just in case the
black king does a castle on the right
side to launch an attack that magnus has
just moved the queen one step to this
particular square the f4 square now
that's it
brand new and
now wesley is really going for it
because he is really chasing that queen
step it back and magnus says okay i have
to we'll later become weaknesses
and kate wesley not being afraid to push
pawns he's pushed on both sides of the
board he's using magnus's favorite
strategy against him pushing the a and h
pawns forward trying to release the
black rooks up the board and there we go
magnus pushes a pawn also on this side
so now if black pushes a pawn on that
left side the pawn that did just move
alice the apon then white will block
things up
i think the big question for wesley so
the reason i don't think this is a great
practical try in a rapid game is because
the black king is going to be stuck
entrenched in the middle of the board we
are turning the tables we are asking you
to ask us the questions share memories
priceless moments there's so many right
yeah um
always think before you act
ad plan is better than no plan right
yeah i like that one bit like life right
yeah yeah but i have something in mind
and uh the player is playing very
quickly and the white knight has has
again maneuvered maneuvered itself to
the left side anything and the bishop
comes out to attack the queen so magnus
must move the queen and
their little tiny
glitch
okay i have to practice that no i think
maybe skiing being in norwegian is where
i have the best bets and magnus is not
ripping off his shirt but there is
definitely
some a little bit of emotion there a
little bit of smile and some music we do
have a bunch of moves i just have to say
you guys that one match has finished
levon aronian playing a draw in this one
currently now then in third place
so he could leap frog over wesley yep
right i think he will leap frog over
wesley most likely unless wesley can
win
the tie breaks
and uh
okay actually no if wesley gets to the
tie breaks i think wesley will secure
that third place but either way he can't
afford to lose in the rapid yeah because
it's uh two and a half points
before this last round is half a point
ahead now yeah yeah so uh wesley have to
take it to uh tie brakes to um secure
and it was getting low and low like you
say and then he also
played
when he was just about to move to
america as well he literally booked a
flight
um on the day that the champions chester
finished yeah yeah so many exciting
games meanwhile in this one we've seen a
trade of pawns a trade of rooks and
magnus there after giving us that blue
steel impression a few moments ago he's
brought the
white queen over and now in conjunction
with her knight they are both eyeing up
black pawn and it's that black pawn on
the d6 square it's incredibly hard to
defend white tonight if it captures it
will deliver a nasty check and it would
be a fork this could be deadly for
wesley so but even after this black king
move he hasn't played it but even after
this black king move white could just
castle and be perfectly safe instead he
has indeed opened things up wesley so he
pushes this pawn forward and now magnus
is moving in for the kill he's just
dropped back the white queen and look at
this the bishop is under fire
how are you going to save this if the
black bishop moves then white's queen is
going to deliver a nasty nasty check it
is game over we'll see wesley so any
moment throw in the towel oh david
look at that it's
run away run away yeah it's teletubby
time for wesley so the black king
running away to safety it's a check the
black king has got to try and hide later
on in the corner but white is going to
win at least a few pawns in the process
look at this it's a double attack
hitting the spawn as well as the check
you see on his face he knows he is about
to win wesley as well you can tell on
his his body language he is resigned to
the defeat
he might play another move or two to try
and cling on but it's hopeless at this
point the black king too exposed he's
about to resign he's about to drop into
fourth place in the tour standings after
a great year for him that's a
disappointing result yeah
couldn't quite finish it off maybe a
little bit um tired wesley saw in the
finals but uh what a season it's been
for him as well
yeah i'm trying to think of a song title
that's uh and now he came in my air okay
it's a queen song under pressure under
pressure
i was listening to it this morning in
the shower
okay wesley is under serious pressure
here he doesn't resign he retreats the
black knight but magnus carson has won a
pawn
and magnus carson is not trading the
queens either
looks the black king in the center if
black recaptures white's pawn in the
middle of the board then white's rook
will swing across and target that black
king
okay wesley desperately trying to remove
the queens from the board but the white
queen forced all the way back she's
still eyeing up the black king this time
from a different angle yeah and uh
impressive how she moved across the
board and every single turn she kept on
piling the pressure
yeah
the winner takes it all in this one and
it's going to be magnus carson black's
king still stuck in the middle and
white's king in the middle as well still
has the right to castle and that's why
magnus carson is going to take the win
and there we go we have a result ah
there it is the final game and the final
win for magnus carlsen in the 2021
season what a performance it's been by
the world champion to win the tour
overall and to finish it off against his
biggest rival this season